at some point I know the audience will
just stop believing me because our
reports about Trump spokeswoman Katrina
Pierson are getting more and more and
more ridiculous over time but the
reports have all been true and I have
yet another report for you today that
may be hard to believe but it is all too
real after last week president uh
presidential candidate Donald Trump said
that President Obama founded Isis now
Katrina Pierson went back on CNN and
said it's actually President Obama who
invaded Afghanistan now of course that's
not true uh it makes absolutely no sense
to just is just suggests that it was in
2001 under george w bush that the United
States entered Afghanistan but doesn't
matter of course this is the same
Katrina Pierson who defended a call for
a pure-breed president the same Katrina
Pierson who blamed a soldier's death in
2004 on President Obama who didn't
become president until January of 2009
here she is on CNN saying hey you know
what President Obama is responsible for
the u.s. invading Afghanistan
take a look pump campaign is back with
us now in Katrina I just want to for
factual sake let's take of just correct
information when you said that Barack
Obama took the country into Afghanistan
it was not during the of course as you
know during the Obama administration
when we first went into Afghanistan
shortly after we're talking about Isis
specifically okay but but your statement
was that Barack Obama took us into
Afghanistan it was his war it was
President Bush who took the country into
Afghanistan shortly after 9/11 but I
want to get a we're talking about
finding of Isis I mean Isis was Isis
came out of the Obama side of the war oh
is that not a fact
no it is not a fact because in 2004 as I
stated in the last segment that AQI
al Qaeda in Iraq was started by Abu
Musab al-zarqawi and then in 2006 it
morphed into Iraq the Islamic state in
Iraq and then later became the Islamic
state in Iraq and Syria but really
maggots yes and after the search as but
also Viktor but often in 2000
Obama demonstration I think the back
course was also Obama saying that they
were the JV team again they the the
incompetence of even recognizing the
threat while he was in office and then
to make it worse going into Libya and
creating a vacuum leaving all those
weapons behind essentially arming the
enemy
I hear that argument but that's not the
argument that Donald Trump has been
making he has made over the last several
days that Barack Obama was the founder
of Isis and then said it was sarcastic
he's put his supporters and his
surrogates as we saw this morning in a
really difficult place not knowing when
he's being sincere when he's being so
Katrina nothing you're saying is true I
love how whenever she's called out on
her lies she tries to find some middle
ground like oh hey Katrina when you said
Obama took us to war in Afghanistan you
were completely factually wrong okay but
Victor can't we agree that at least
Obama is the Antichrist and responsible
for the death of John F Kennedy no
Katrina we also can't say that and this
is a known technique Louis to try to
find the middle ground to sort of try to
establish some agreement from which then
you can have smaller differences but she
just fails miserably every single time
she really I we we think she should be
fired because she seems to be completely
incompetent but yeah who would take her
place is the real question
gilli Baumgardner even right now if it's
scary and and uh yeah it's it's just
non-stop Obama bashing I'm not sure with
that achieves she just spews nonsense
like Trump all the time and I although I
will say this uh at least she admits
even if it's just a one-word admission
she will admit when she said something
completely false
she said no in other words agreeing that
no it was not true what she said but a
whole bunch of other reasons why you
should still accept basically everything
she says without any kind of scrutiny
whatsoever anything else would be
liberal media bias
I've actually been hearing from people
as Trump likes to say people are telling
me that President Obama actually
assassinated Franz Ferdinand and set in
motion the events that led to World War
one now I'm not saying that but people
have been telling me that Louis and
maybe we need to stop for a sec
and and figure out what the hell is
going on there's only so far you can go
in in retro actively blaming Obama
things that happened when he wasn't even
a senator uh I feel like the late
nineties of the limit for what you can
blame Obama for now of course he was
basically a kid at the time but but that
that's about as far back as you can go
world war one world war two that's a
little too far it is a little too far uh
but um miss Pearson and and Trump might
say you haven't taken it far enough so
that maybe even the civil war we can
blame Obama for I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between eleven hundred and
sixteen hundred pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering twenty five dollars a
free driving credit if you sign up at
join Zipcar dot-com slash david support
our show reduce your carbon emissions
and you're spending on cars sign up at
join Zipcar dot-com slash david